through the use of AI found on the r and
I were able to determine the two
Essential Elements necessary in
constructing a hit country music
song the two Essential Elements
necessary in constructing a hit country
music song are as follows number one a
unique hook which must also be used as
the title of the song Thank God zes of
countries boys dig deeper 5:00 somewhere
deeper Save a Horse Ride a
Cowboy gety Up that particular title
teaches us a valuable lesson in the
process just because it's Unique does
not mean it can't be dumb dumb is almost
preferable in a unique hook for a hit
country song country and western we're
looking for contagious dialogue here
people quotables she thinks my tractor's
sexy Dumber no sure no sho's no problem
Dumber I've got it Beer for My Horses
Bingo or an activity something that you
all do something along the lines of I
don't know a the fishing in the
dark darts I was going to say that too
that's mostly just smoking darts but it
needs to be more catchy more crafty more
clever needs to be more poetic how about
uh smoking darts in the rain no you
can't do that well then was that me your
Dart would go out okay so you're smoking
darts when it's dry well it have to be
dry to smok them dry darts uh Blue Sky
darts best darts are ones that's warms
hot darts we're not trying to darts
McMurray try anything once smoking in
the summer smoking summer do smoking in
the sun DS when it's sunny
it's
Sun our hit single shall be
christened Su darts it's
perfect Katie what's number
[Music]
two